Going out and talking to random voters is
a really great thing to do during elections.
Truly an MSNBC did that yesterday and hilariously
ran into a voter who said it is your coverage
of Bernie Sanders.
MSNBC is coverage of Bernie Sanders that made
her decide to vote for Bernie Sanders.
This is super interesting.
Ari Melbourne was in Manchester, New Hampshire
yesterday.
The day of the primary goes up to a voter.
She says, it was you that made me vote for
Bernie.
Let's take a look at the video.
What about over here?
Who did you vote for?
I voted for Bernie.
Um, although there are a number of candidates
that I really like, and so I felt like I,
I, when I finished voting, I was still undecided,
um, including Elizabeth, including Michael
Bennett.
Now that's sort of a paradox to, to decide
and then feel undecided.
So you're a complex person.
Well, yes, but I want to say the reason I
went for Bernie is on, because of MSNBC and
gone, I think it is completely cynical to
say that he's lost 50% of his vote on from
the last time when there were two candidates.
Now there are multiple wonderful candidates
who would be great presidents and people that
we could, I think that we can unify and get
behind, but the, the, the kind of the stock
Bernie CISM cynicism that I heard from a number
of people, I watch MSNBC constantly.
So I heard that from a number of commentators.
And so that just, it made me angry enough.
I said, okay, Bernie's got my vote.
This is such a
interesting point.
What you're saying is, and we take criticism
cause we're journalists, right?
We gotta be open minded.
You're saying that hearing from people, whether
it's gas contributors, the conversations you've
heard that you felt were designed to tear
down a Senator Sanders or just quote unquote
stop him actually endeared him to you.
Absolutely.
Now you'll notice how Ari Melbourne slips
in.
You're saying you've heard from guests and
contributors these things.
Well.
What about hosts are in Melbourne sort of
slipping in.
You're not talking about MSNBC hosts.
Obviously you're talking about guests who
are not affiliated with us.
You're talking about contributors who of course
are actually affiliated with MSNBC.
Uh, but in reality, it's also been the hosts
on MSNBC.
Now the word cynicism was mentioned by the
voter.
Cynicism is defined as an inclination to believe
that people are motivated purely by self-interest.
Skepticism sometimes has overlap with cynicism.
What's interesting about this is that on the
one hand, one of the biggest contributors
to the Republican national committee has been
the parent company of MSNBC, Comcast, the
big cable and internet company provider.
Check out some of these donations from last
year, 45,000 bucks to the RNC, another 45,000
bucks to the RNC, 15,000 bucks to the RNC.
And what you have to understand is this, it
might seem like there's a contradiction here.
How can MSNBC be both quote, leftist editorially
in their content and be financially supporting
the reelection of of Donald Trump?
There's actually a lot of cynicism that is
required here in order to understand this.
First of all, remember that a lot of these
big corporations are donating to both sides
because they want to be able to Curry favor
with whoever it is that is ultimately going
to be an office.
And the truth is that on a lot of issues,
including regulatory issues with media, you've
got similarities between Republicans and Democrats.
On net neutrality, you've seen a significant
division between Democrats and Republicans,
but on a lot of other issues that impact the
day to day operation of these big media conglomerates,
Republicans and Democrats are both willing
to help, let's put it that way.
The second thing to understand is that MSNBC
is not progressive.
It's an establishment democratic editorial
perspective shrouded in veiling, I guess veiling,
I guess we would say.
Um, a, a big corporate priorities that are
very similar.
When you look at Fox as news corporation,
parent company and MSNBC is Comcast.
They are liberal, center left really editorially
as a business decision, but a lot of their
priorities are very, very similar to any other
media conglomerate.
Now, number three, Trump being president is
clearly good for MSNBC.
His ratings.
I've admitted it's good for our show as well.
I've not hidden from you that our show has
had some of the most explosive growth in our
history under Donald Trump's presidency.
I don't want the guy reelected.
I don't plan to vote for him.
I want what's best for the country.
But I've admitted that because it is part
of the interesting thing that has been taking
place in this country over the last several
years.
But if it has to be a Democrat, MSNBC wants
it to be a centrist establishment Democrat.
Now, as far as the voters point, she's right.
Um, some of the analyses on MSNBC have been
horrible.
Chuck Todd talking about Bernie supporters
as Brown shirts.
Absolutely crazy comparing raw support for
Bernie in 20 when there were two serious candidates
with support for Bernie in 2020 when there
are five at least serious candidates.
It's not just cynical, it's dishonest.
It's deceptive.
And kudos to Ari Malborough.
I've always seen Ari as a pretty good faith
actor.
He seems genuinely wanting to know how the
world is rather than to sort of push a particular
worldview.
He seemed genuinely interested in learning
more.
It might've been more interesting if the person
doing the interviews from for MSNBC had been
more caught off guard in some way or reacted
in some way, but it was already Melbourne
doing the interviews and he seemed genuinely
interested in hearing what this voter had
to say.
Uh, I'm curious whether other folks have experienced
a similar push where the coverage of a particular
candidate by a particular network has pushed
them towards or away candidates.
Let me know.